in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jason
and Tiffany are with us hey guys how are
you
well hey Dave welcome welcome good to
have you where are you guys live we live
right outside of Atlanta Georgia Oh fine
well thanks thanks for visiting us here
in Nashville yeah honored to have it you
came North right into the snow so you're
here to do a debt-free scream how much
have you paid off one hundred and twelve
thousand dollars I love it how long did
that take twenty eight months making
what kind of money during that time we
started off at 85,000 and currently
we're making together a hundred and
twenty thousand very good what are you
to do for a living I'm an HR huh I'm an
auditor ah very cool good for you
so what kind of debt was the hundred and
twelve thousand what did you people buy
Wow
well 108 thousand of that was student
loans and the other four thousand was
credit cards okay so both of your
student loans or both of our student
loan okay yeah all right cool yeah forty
was hers about sixty something was mine
okay yeah how long have you guys been
married before years in March so mainly
student loans a little bit of credit
cards yes so what happened two years and
four months ago that put you on this
journey well I have taken your class
before I met Jason I had just graduated
from college and I never really liked it
my dad allowed me to have a credit card
and I and even though he said hey you
can use it if you need it I just hate it
using it and so I always my parents had
warned me don't go into a huge amount of
debt for education and I didn't listen I
really wanted to go to that school so I
went and it occurred all this this dead
and I really hate it so I took your
class you're a Financial Peace
University class and I graduated from
there and then few years later I've well
actually that year actually I met Jason
and we started dating and then we became
engaged and I just I told pay I took
this class and I really think that the
principle
that they've teaches is biblical and
that is something that we should do and
so he finally came around he was a
little bit more liberal well when she
she felt a mention that I had a plan
when we got married to like hey we're
gonna pay off the student loan like 10
years and she looked at it was like
that's too long so I was like okay well
I guess that is kind of long I had
already been playing paying like 10
years on her already and barely budged
it yeah and so we just I was more
focused on creating the nest egg mm-hmm
and just listened to you in a radio I
got you know caught onto the vision and
you know we started to that's no but not
destined oh yeah death snowball the
whole process and just took off from
there mmm okay but you'd already been
married a little while when you actually
started yes so what happened that caused
you to actually start after you've been
marry me been very year and a half two
years right honestly I just I not to put
my I'm not trying to say anything it's
my husband but I think it just took some
time for him to kind of you really want
to get aggressive with it and he like I
said he was more of a free spirit and so
he was his focus was more so on the nest
egg and mine was more so let's get out
of debt so that we can build wealth and
that we can give back to you were just
too sweet so I mean you - did you have
any like real big budget fights we still
struggle in that area just to be honest
and really just what's the biggest pain
what's the biggest fight about the
grocery budget you know I want I want
more I want to eat healthy and I also
want to be able to explore with
different things and so he's like you
don't need that much for groceries I'm
like look I'm the one going into the
store and pricing things and I know what
I want to make and so he's like you
don't need that much and I think he's
gonna eventually yeah so Sharon Sharon
the way she fixed me on that years ago
there's been healthy just had to have
been cheap and she made me go the store
with her and I figured out you couldn't
do it you couldn't do it on what I was
trying to get it fixed it I'm like I was
trying to head it all up and I'm like
you're right heck with it I give up
and so we raised we raised the budget at
that point on the groceries and and now
whenever she says something about it I'm
just like yeah okay listen cuz I'm not
I'm I lost that fight permanently Jason
yeah but it's a good way to lose a fight
though yeah yeah and in the other part
was I like you know the little
entertainment going to the movies and
little snacks and stuff a little blow
money in when we first got this thing
started I had like what two hundred is
my blow money or whatever and she got me
down to zero and I was like can I get a
skittle one raisinet yeah my lunch is my
PBJ for like there you go I like it
that's gone well it wasn't worth it now
that you're dead oh yes oh it's awesome
I mean just the freedom that we have to
do some of the things that we want to do
like travel and bless other people it's
just so freeing it's undescribable and
it's something that we think that
everybody should try to achieve because
just the legacy that you can go within
your own family it's just something that
you can't really describe Jason have you
seen the math now freed up to build the
nest egg now that you don't have the
debt yeah yeah so it starts working on
your deal now right yeah yeah it did it
was it was kind of awesome because like
I said was like a shot in the arm she
woke me up a little bit like yeah I said
I've been paralyzed for ten years and
never moved and now got that momentum
going and you know I got really fired up
like towards the ruler really towards
the end yeah I was with it I wanted to
help my family because it was going to a
family reunion and I wanted to just you
know really contribute to that make it
really big and was I was able to move
some moment money around as far as you
know bringing our take home pay a little
bit more and it was a we got done
earlier than what we anticipated I was
like oh and I was able to bless and was
ever have a great time with our
it was just really awesome and you know
they're not the whole thing Dave
that's what money's for yeah yeah yeah
it's not for banks yeah well
congratulations you guys well done Jason
and Tiffany Atlanta Georgia one hundred
and twelve thousand dollars paid off in
28 months making 85 now making 120 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream -
why well Don you - very very very well
done man that's just awesome hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show I want
to write a song I want to own my own
business I want to make more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year so wish